cnn reports that music icon dolly parton  says that there's only one person that  she would want to play her in a movie  and it's none other than tony  award-winning broadway powerhouse  kristen chenoweth such a  makes so much brilliant she says kristen  is absolutely fantastic and if there's  ever a biopic she would be her first  choice i mean rossi  it's a no-brainer but i can  why am i going parliament and you're  going dolly parton i look like i i'm a  judge in a british  show  give me a gavel what is going on i don't  know but i am feeling myself in this  size i stumble into the bed stumble in  the kitchen  look at me pour myself a cup of ambition  watch out  kristin chenoweth i'm coming for your  gig